I've had this romance with the ocean my
entire life
when I was a kid I aspired to become a
diver so I could go and see this wonder
and this beauty myself and then I spent
decades you know exploring and enjoying
that world
the way of water was an opportunity to
put two things that I love together I
loved the world building opportunity
that I'm blessed with when I make an
Avatar film and I love the ocean
[Music]
there's a very big parallel between
Pandora and our planet the most obvious
connection is the coral reefs and the
tropical atoll formations especially in
the Central and Western Pacific
all of our species of coral and large
soft invertebrate animals and so on that
we'd have here on Earth we put
equivalence to those in our Reef
ecosystem in the way of water
the way of water connects all things
to take indigenous culture here on our
planet and put it through the lens of
Pandora we did a lot of research about
real indigenous cultures that are very
tightly associated with the ocean they
have this deep respect for the Harmony
and balance of nature they're tattooing
their body and facial tattooing we did
our own kind of Pandora and version of
that
[Music]
there are the sea people in Indonesia
that live on stilted homes and live on
rafts and so on we looked at things like
that and we see a couple of different
villages in the way of water that use an
architecture that uses the local trees
all Navi culture doesn't want to cut
down a tree saw it up into Lumber build
things they want to integrate in a very
natural and graceful and symbiotic way
into their environment so we had to come
up with their architecture
they have a symbiotic culture with an
intelligent species we would probably
take a glance at and say oh that's a
whale but of course it's not a whale
it's a pandoran version
[Music]
to have the underwater experience and
the magic and mystery of that maybe it
will reconnect people with what we are
presently losing here on this planet
it's an adventure It's a drama it has
huge emotional Stakes but our hope is
that the film Works to celebrate and
fall in love with again the world of
Pandora
foreign
[Music]